foreign
take a moment to think about your sex
life
don't worry I'm a professional I ask
this question all the time
my guess is that most of you are
thinking about solo pleasure or the
interaction between you and someone else
perhaps
there's probably very few of you who are
thinking about how your sex life
connects to wider Dynamics in society
let me explain by starting somewhere a
little different
the gender pay Gap has reduced in the
last three decades in the UK
and we have more women in senior
management positions than ever before
but there is also still
such a long way to go
Britain only ranks 21st in the world for
gender equality
and not all women benefit equally from
the advances we've made so far
today I'm going to tell you how the
orgasm gap which is data about gender
inequality from sex science
is a lesser known but powerful indicator
of just how far we still have to go
progress towards equality in any area is
about breaking free of entrenched social
norms and this is especially the case in
sex
in my work as a clinical psychologist
specializing in helping people with
their sex lives
I noticed that we're often unaware
of how much of how we are sexually is
dictated by forces outside of ourselves
or outside of our sexual relationships
what we should say how we're supposed to
be what we're supposed to look like
who does what and when
what we're supposed to be into
these scripts they're all written for us
and we learn them
from language from peers and from the
media
I don't know about you but I'm starting
to see a small change in these Scripts
these days my social media feeds are
full of posts about women's sexual
empowerment and women's bodily autonomy
compared to say five years ago and this
is great
but in my work I notice that this change
has not yet translated to real life
and to the bedroom
not that everyone has sex there but you
know what I mean
I see plenty of women in my clinic who
tell me that they feel more empowered
than ever
to take up space to call out misogyny to
demand a seat at the table
but when it comes to their sex lives
they can't seem
to bring themselves
to feel empowered in the same way
they tell me that they feel silenced
disempowered and made to feel that they
are the problem
and they don't know how to tackle it
so why is this happening
well
we used to think that women's orgasms
were hard to come by
and that and that because they were
tricky
this was the obvious explanation as to
why when CIS men and CIS women have sex
together it's more often the man who
leaves feeling satisfied
this is a common myth
and it's kind of got in the way of us
really noticing and questioning this
imbalance of pleasure across genders
this tricky orgasm myth has been
challenged by various pieces of sex
research over the last few decades
and we now know that when people
masturbate
there is no difference in the rates of
orgasm
or the time taken to orgasm across
genders
turning this idea of women's orgasms
being more complex or taking longer on
its head
but this sex science and the fact that
only a minority of women can come from
vaginal penetration without any clitoral
stimulation
still not that widely known
leaving many women feeling like they are
the problem
that they're taking too long or needing
something unusual to get there
when in fact they're entirely normal
feeling abnormal leads them to fake it
and faking it gives their partner the
wrong idea of what women's bodies need
meaning the next woman who tries to
assert what she wants or needs with that
partner esteem is difficult or labeled
as hard work
as a result research tells us that men
consistently overestimate how often
women orgasm during partnered sex
and underestimate how often women are
Faking It
this is the reason why some women
describe partnered sex as like
listening to your favorite song but
having the radio switched off before it
gets to the best bit
but why does it matter
well the first thing to say is that
orgasms are not the be-all and end-all
of good sex and we mustn't treat them as
if they are
good sex can bring connection stress
relief affirmation intimacy and fun
and orgasms are just another reward like
these that serve to make us feel good
and keep humans coming back for more
but what if the pleasure of one group of
people is consistently privileged over
the pleasure of another
what does that tell us about our society
I mentioned earlier that people of all
genders can orgasm at a similar rate
when they're alone and that rate is
about 95 of the time
the orgasm Gap refers to data from sex
science which tells us how our chances
of orgasming can move from this 95
percent when we have sex with another
person
the biggest Gap we see is for women
having sex with men
when their chances of orgasming drop
from this 95 they might expect alone to
around 65 percent with a regular partner
we see an even bigger Gap emerging with
casual or hook-up sex between women and
men
when women's chance of orgasming drops
further still
crucially men's rate of orgasming when
having sex with women stays around 85 to
95 whether that's a regular partner
casual sex and just as reliably as when
they're on their own
we don't see such a dramatic orgasm Gap
when LGBT plus people have sex with each
other
so for example women having sex with
women can expect an orgasm rate only
slightly less than when they're on their
own
this data is important
because it tells us that it's gender
which is responsible for inequality and
the experience of orgasms not Anatomy
not capacity for pleasure
but rather whose pleasure is prioritized
as most important
as a society we still aren't signed up
to an idea that women's sexual pleasure
is as important as men's
we're happy to strive for it
but only if the route to achieving it
doesn't jeopardize men's pleasure in the
process
now there is a complex mix of factors
which maintains the orgasm Gap
firstly not knowing what's normal
and feeling as if it's your body which
is wrong
falling for this old idea that your
orgasms are somehow tricky
even though you know that they're not
when you're alone
secondly women being socialized to put
other people's needs first and being
polite
so as to not hurt someone else's
feelings or ego
and lastly the simple fact that the
patriarchy shows itself in the way men
and women have sex together
the sheer physicality of a sexual script
which favors penis and vagina sex Above
All Else as real sex
simply suits men's Anatomy more
this is one of the reasons we don't see
such a dramatic orgasm Gap when women
have sex with other women and we can
learn from this
ditch the script and have more sex which
looks like the sex you enjoy alone
so
what are we to do
stop faking it
yes I know you've all done it
and you're so so good at it
I know it comes from a place of not
feeling normal or wanting to communicate
something or trying to protect someone
else's feelings
but all faking does is strengthen this
patriarchal script it means your needs
are less likely to be met over time
we can also notice how inequality shows
up in the bedroom
is it okay with you that your needs are
sidelined in favor of someone else's
how does that fit with your values
around equality and other areas of your
life
it's okay to be motivated by something
other than orgasms when you have sex
but this should be your choice to make
not some kind of sexual glass ceiling
based on gender
and lastly by showing up for each other
if more women felt able to be upfront
about their pleasure and what their body
needs this would pave the way for women
collectively to benefit
it would mean the next woman who tries
to be open about what her body needs
would be less likely to be dismissed
as complex or unusual
it would change the story
it would redress the balance
but this journey isn't just for women to
take men can show up here also by
believing women when they say what they
need
these women are not the outliers you
think they are
they are the voice of change
men can also show up by understanding
that women's capacity for pleasure is
equal to their own and by genuinely
championing sex which has Mutual
pleasure at its core
even if that means sacrificing their own
more comfortable position of privilege
from time to time
so
let's start a revolution
after all who knows what the impact of
gender equality behind closed doors
might have on the rest of society
thank you
[Applause]